احم وفي سياق نفسه شهدت احياء شعبيه في
ولايات القصرين وسوسه وبنزر مناوشات
وعمليه كر وفر بين شبان ووحدات الامن
استخدمت في هذه المناوشات الغازات المسيله
للدموع لتفريق المتظاهرين الذين كانوا
يناددون باجراءات الرئيس قيس سعيد
التونسيه في بيان الاطراف لم تسمي بها
بتحريض مراهقين وذوي سوابق اجراميه للقيام
باعمال شغب في احياء شعبيه موضحه انها
تسعى للقبض عليهم واحالتهم للعداله
وزاره الداخليه التونسيه قالت ايضا انها
اوقفت ثلاثه اشخاص خط طول الاعتداء على
قوات الامن والاضرار بالممتلكات الخاصه
والعامه في الضواحي الجنوبيه لتونس
العاصمه
ينضم الينا من تونس مراسل جزيره سيف الدين
بوعلاك سيف الدين اصداء ما جرى بالامس
وكيف يتم متابعه كل هذه التطورات اليوم
بالفعل فدا كانت مظاهره او عده مظاهرات قد
نظمت يوم امس في شارع الحبيب بورقيبه في
مكان اخر في العاصمه تقريبا اغلب
الحساسيات المعارضه للرئيس سعيد شاركت
ونظم في هذه المظاهره تقريبا هناك مظاهره
كبيره لجبهه الخلاص الوطني المكونه من
حركه النهضه وحزب قلب تونس وحمله مواطننا
ضد الانقلاب في الجانب الاخر من شارع
الحبيب بورقيبه كان هناك تنسيقيه الاحزاب
الديمقراطيه الاجتماعيه وهي حزب التيار
الديمقراطي الحسبه الجمهوري حزب القطب
الحداثي والتكثر من اجل العمل والحريات
وحزب العامه وحزب العمال عفوا بالاضافه
الى عدد من المنظمات المجتمع المدني
والحساسيه همم الشبابيه تقريبا
المتظاهرين همم الدعوه الى رحيل القيسي
سعيد هذا احد الشعارات الكبرى تحميل
الرئيس سعيد مسؤوليه تتده الاوضاع
الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه
والماليه في البلاد مسؤوليه تدهور الاوضاع
المعيشيه التونسيين من ارتفاع الاسعار
وافقدان عده مواد اساسيه هذا هو همم
التشخيص او الاشعارات التي رفعت هناك ايضا
دعوات الى رحيل الرئيس كاس سعيد دعوات الى
الانتخابات الرئاسيه مبكره هذا هو تقريبا
رفع من شعارات والدعوات من
المتحدثين من القيادات همم السياسيه
والشبابيه والمدنيه بالنسبه
لرئيس كان له التحرك سابق الرابع عشر من
يناير تحدث فيه وكان قام بجوله في شارع
الحبيبته تحدث عن الاوضاع الاجتماعيه
وتعاهده بمعالجه الاوضاع الاقتصاديه
التونسيين وايضا يقول ان لا ما كان همم
خونه والمتامرين في الخارج وانه سيعمل على
تطهير البلاد من الفساد
والمفسدين كما يقول الرئيس قيس سعيد في
هذا في الجانب السياسي في دارو هناك جانب
اخر وهو موعد انتخابي قريب والدور الثاني
من الانتخابات التشريعيه اليوم ستعلن او
من المفترض ان تعلن هيئه الانتخابات في
مؤتمر الصحفي عن موعد اجراء الدور الثاني
بناء الانتخابات التي بدورها اثاره جدلا
واسعا في تونس بالنظر الى نسبه الاقبال
الاضعف همم منذ ثوره وحتى مقابله ثوره 12%
فقط شاركوا في الدور الاول وهو ما حدا
بالبعض الى همم القول ان الرئيس سعيد
وخريطه الطريق فشل ذريعا وان المشاركه همم
ضعيفه جدا لعدد من لعدد ضعيف من الناخبين
هو الدليل على ان همم الرئيس قيس سعيد لا
يحكم باراده الشعبيه بينما الرئيس سعيد
يقول ان همم
انتظار الدور الثاني لاحتساب نسبه
المشاركه وانه سيستكمل خريطه الطريقه التي
اعلن عنها في دانام شكرا لك سيف الدين
بوعد